it feels like every day a new celebrity
announces an nft project that you've
just gotta buy they hype you up send you
to a discord group and they promise you
a road map riches
in other words they promise you the
world that is right up to the day of the
mint but i want to know what happens
after that after everyone buys in what
happens to the thousands of fans who
just invested into their favorite
celebrity do they go to the moon and get
rich or do the fans lose money that's
what we're discussing today i've
gathered 20 celebrity nft projects and i
want to take you on a where are they now
journey i didn't pick them ahead of time
knowing which ones are doing poorly or
doing well and let me say ahead of time
this is not about you know what is a
scam what's not and i'm definitely not
endorsing any of these projects i just
want to look at the facts like how are
all these projects doing what was the
price what is the price today and my
hope is that by zooming out we can get a
macro view of whether it's a good idea
to invest in celebrity nfts in the first
place and we're going to start with
justin bieber who promoted a project
called the inbetweeners which is a
collection of bear nfts and it's the
first thing you see when you click on
his instagram with 254 million followers
at an initial mint price of 0.27
ethereum the project has been pretty
popular for the most part even though
sales have dried up a little bit despite
justin continuing to support it the
current price is down about 30 which in
this market is decent and can be
described as not a total disaster which
is more than i can say for our next
celebrity example takashi six nine six
nine is known for many things he's known
as being a rapper in the most technical
of census he's known as being a snitch
in the most legal of senses but he's
also known as being a serial nft
promoter he's one of the few people on
this list actually who's promoted
multiple projects the first one trolls
had an initial min price of two solana
but trolls was accused of being a scam
when six nine didn't deliver on the
promises big shock and it quickly
plummeted to one percent of its original
price and even takashi 69 admitted it
was basically a cash grab but that his
next project called jean a would be
different i know a lot of you guys are
wondering what happened with six nine's
last nft project
i want to first start off by saying i
apologize i apologize because i jumped
in to the nft community without knowing
what an nft was i didn't know what an
nft was i didn't know what crypto was i
wasn't well informed it was a paid
partnership that i
took advantage of and i said you know
what let me get into something that i
don't know
that much about so to all my fans who
joined that i extremely apologize
for that being done
what makes this so different what makes
g a nft collection so different
is that it's not a paid partnership this
is my brand so with all that said was
jean a different how did it do
well
not great the original price was .22
ethereum which you can now buy for .035
ethereum so the price has fallen by like
85 percent and things aren't going well
it looks like more of the same now for
the record the reason i'm using ethereum
and solana prices instead of pricing
everything in us dollars is because with
crypto crashing i want to eliminate the
fluctuations in the crypto market as
much as possible i think it's unfair to
say this nft cost four thousand dollars
now it costs two thousand dollars
without acknowledging okay well ethereum
has fallen by fifty percent so the idea
is by pricing everything in the currency
it was bought and we can ignore these
fluctuations and focus on actually how
the project did and with that said let's
talk about one of the worst celebrity
nft projects this year lana rhodes
kryptosis now we've kind of covered this
in detail already cryptosys was a hot
mess and not the kind people were
expecting there were too many promises
way too many disappointments and at a
mint price of 0.1 ethereum the project
is now down over 99
and what did lana rhodes do about it she
accused her followers of being too
negative and said they put her in a bad
headspace and she's left the internet
because of it but not all nft projects
go poorly and up next we've got a good
example of a project that's doing well
we're talking about garyvee with his v
friends and i've got to say he's kind of
crushing it with stick figure caliber
drawings proving once again it's not
about how good your art is because these
are five-year-old doodle-level drawings
but they're selling for the price of an
economy car with a mint price between
2.5 ethereum and 0.5 ethereum early
investors are very happy their
investments are up several hundred
percent i think they're selling for like
over six ethereum now and i think the x
factor is obviously garyvee himself and
the project's exclusive access to vcon
which is an nft event he throws every
single year now as a quick reminder i'm
not endorsing v friends i don't think
you should go buy one just because the
price went up before doesn't mean it
will continue to go up and our next
celebrity is a great example of this
reese witherspoon is a famous actress
who promoted the nfc project called
world of women with a media deal to
produce movies and tv shows and at first
glance it seems like a slam dunk
promotion because at an initial mint
price of 0.08 ethereum it's now selling
for a lot more than that so if you'd
invested early when she first tweeted
about it you'd be doing pretty well
however her biggest announcement came in
the middle of february which is actually
near the top of the price of world of
women so if you had invested then you'd
basically be down 75 of your original
investment which makes this project a
good example of it's not what you buy
it's also when you buy it now keeping
with this theme of female celebrities in
crypto we're going to move on to our
next example lindsay lohan she promoted
something called the canine cartel nft
which is a dog nft minting for .05
ethereum fast forward to today lindsay
has deleted her tweet promoting it and
the project is down 90
now this whole thing of delete and
distance isn't exactly an original idea
many celebrities have figured this out
it's what john wall did who's a
basketball player who created the baby
ballers in ft which we've also talked
about its website is now deleted but
originally it was minted for 0.15
ethereum and is now also down 90
with most investors being unable to sell
their nfts at all and this is just kind
of a recurring trend athletes and bad
nfts really go well together our next
celebrity tyson fury follows the same
pattern he had a collection that minted
for 330 to 550
and it's unclear if you can even sell
these now because basically no one
wanted them in the first place only a
few hundred sold so he didn't make a lot
of money but you know who did make a lot
of money floyd mayweather floyd launched
floyd's world at a mint price of 0.15
ethereum and it sold pretty well but
currently they're selling for less than
one percent of their original mint price
which judging from their onboarding
video makes sense because this isn't
exactly a high budget operation
welcome everyone do you want to learn
how to gain access to floyd's world it's
easy just follow me
uh honestly no i don't i think i'm good
but we're gonna keep with this theme of
bad nft animations for our next
celebrity kevin hart who recently
released a project called confessions
from the heart which is part nft project
part roku animated series which is
supposed to promote it except the roku
animated series is like almost
indescribably bad for someone who has
access to millions of dollars this is
when i realized you just don't know who
people are it looks like a college
student's project or something and if
floyd's animations are so bad they're
almost funny kevin hart's animations are
so bad that they aren't funny at all the
only thing that might be funny is this
project's current price it's down
already 50 in only a month which
it's just
it's just rough i mean what did you
expect guys mike tyson is up next with a
personal nft collection which he sold
for .15 2.5 ethereum not much to say
here the prices are considerably down
from its all-time high in september and
i'm sure you've noticed sort of a trend
here where projects have a boom and then
a bust they initially get hyped they get
sales and then over time the celebrity
and the holders just kind of lose
interest in the nft and that kind of
makes sense it's hard to maintain that
initial hype no matter how good the
intentions and that's the lesson of our
next celebrity steph curry who created a
famous basketball nft collection called
the 2974 collection and it was a big
deal because he said that a hundred
percent of profits would go to charity
which sounds great but at an initial
mint price of 500
the initial hype was high and now the
price is significantly lower than that
and sales are mostly dead so i guess the
question is how do you avoid these boom
bust cycles of hype and then
disappointment well many nft celebrities
have tried a lot of different things
some like french montana a rapper
experiment with real world utility
french montana's project is called coke
boys kicks which was pitched as a
digital sneaker which is paired with
like a physical one now this project
just wasn't unique enough to escape the
fate of many mmts before them and coke
boys kicks are now down nearly 80
percent so it's hard to avoid the death
of hype although some manage it better
than others our next group you guys know
i'm not the biggest fan of it's the nelk
boys they released their project called
meta card at an initial mint price of
0.75 ethereum and sold 23 million
however even so the price has only
dipped like 20
in the last several months which frankly
really surprised me i mean i guess the
nelk fan base just won't let this one
die which fair enough uh neither will
our next example stan lee's nft
collection wow that's a bad segue uh
let's talk about that though i mean what
a disaster that was he released
something from beyond the grave called
choc reverse nft and obviously it's not
his fault it's some like greedy
corporate estate uh which released it in
its name and at a mint price of 200 for
crappy art i imagine the marvel's exacts
are pretty proud okay maybe that's a
cheap shot at marvel studios but then
again you know what else is cheap these
nfts now they're down 75 from their
initial mint price which again is just
sort of the norm across these celebrity
nfts regardless of where you look most
of the nft market
tends to do worse after the mint it's
just how it is even so-called real
artists like grimes will release stuff
like you know this earth collection she
did originally it'll cost 7 500 and now
it's selling for 200
asap rocky faced the same problem with
his project which initially sold for 2
000 and is now selling for 400 and
that's not even to talk about all the
cash grabs going on you also have things
like little uzi vert with his eternal
beings nft which initially minted for
2.5 solana and now he's abandoned the
project and it's basically become
unsellable these abandonments happen all
the time too because you have people
like jake paul he releases the sacred
nft project or partners with it and now
he abandons it and it's down 90
so not only do you have to worry about
the general problem of hype dying you
also have to worry about your celebrity
just abandoning the project in general
and i know this has been a lot so i kind
of want to summarize a lot of this
information i just gave you let's kind
of recap how these projects did i've
shared 20 of them with you and of those
20 only two of them are still above mint
price the friends and world of women
another two of these projects were at
least close to their initial mint price
maybe within 20 or 30 percent while the
rest are down nearly 90 to 99 and are
basically worthless so what's the
lessons well firstly celebrity nfts are
definitely not about the arc the most
successful project is a series of
scribbles so if anything i learned that
nfts are just about building and
maintaining hype and the truth about
hype is that it's easy to build at first
because you can just promise people
anything but it's hard to deliver on and
maintain in the long run the other
lesson that i learned which i haven't
talked about much is that there's an
asymmetric risk to buying nfts because
while the average investor of these nft
projects has lost a lot of money
all the celebrities who delivered on
them made money i mean it's very easy to
make money selling in nft because you
can make them for cheap and sell them
for hundreds to thousands of dollars
which means that while it's a big risk
for you as a buyer it's not a risk at
all for the celebrity which might be why
they like them so much and for these
reasons and the general risk of scams
and rug pulls and the fact you'd be
relying on a celebrity for your
financial well-being i'd have to say
celebrity nfts are a bad bet i jumped in
to the nft community without knowing
what an nft was i didn't know what an
nft was i didn't know what crypto was i
wasn't well informed which i guess did i
really have to prove that in the first
place no you probably already knew that
but i think it was interesting taking a
look at the life cycle of these
different nft projects and i hope you've
learned something